let me bring these stories together
because we we have a story here this is
from timcast.com police raid Virginia
restaurant that defied covet orders
owner says State officials tried to
strip him and his guests of their
constitutional rights the long story
short in Fredericksburg there is Gourmet
gormeltz I'm sorry gormelts is the name
of the place right and it's a business
that refused to shut down during the the
lockdowns and the masks and all that
stuff so they are trying to take away
the liquor license they say police
officers entered a Fredericksburg
Virginia restaurant and executed award
to confiscate alcohol and Records
pertaining to the sale of alcohol after
the state's Alcoholic Beverage Control
Authority ABC revoked the restaurants
liquor licenses following the owner's
refusal to follow mandates issued during
the covid pandemic the restaurant's
owner Matt Strickland had his alcohol
license suspended for 90 days in
September after they ruled he willfully
and knowingly ignored mandates
so I wake up and I watch this video
where these cops are going in and
they're and they're they're basically
shutting him down serving this warrant I
think he got like a 90-day uh suspension
and uh my first edit I got two things to
say on this and then we'll expand
because you've certainly you know been
dealing with this stuff one
you should watch this video and you
should share the video and if you live
in Fredericksburg you should tell
everybody you know these cops are not
welcome in your business if they want to
destroy a man's life because of
unconstitutional edict they don't
deserve a hot dog from your store they
don't deserve a new sweater they don't
deserve a cheeseburger the it is p is
non-violent Civil Disobedience to solve
this problem let these officers know you
are shunned look anti-food life say this
stuff but they don't run businesses they
don't have jobs some of them do I get it
but the cops aren't worried about that
I'll tell you what they are worried
about when the the you have the back the
blue people the Maga people the last
line of people actually defending the
police and then the cops want to pull
something like this simply say officer
thank you for your service now get out
of my store I will not serve you and
then see how long that they're going to
cops being like look I'm not shutting
this business down I'll I'll never be
able to show my face in this town again
it used to be that way people used to
fear that no if I if I do that mayor
they'll never show my face nope now they
don't care so this guy films them good
the second thing I'm going to say is
Luke on Saturday do you want to go down
to Fredericksburg let's do it let's do
it let's support this business
and let's support the people who are
doing the good things and and and when
they're punished unjustly we should try
to do everything we can to help out
during those situations yeah I imagine
what what we could what can we do
peaceful organizing just to to highlight
this stuff
and I think highlighting is the first
thing and I think you know maybe I'll go
down and take a tour of Fredericksburg
see what's see what's going on maybe uh
you know we can reach out to this guy
Matt see what's up and ask him about
what happened and then get the full
details and maybe keep shedding a light
on this stuff you guys should see the
video and if you haven't seen it you
should watch it as we're talking right
now so you understand what's happening I
mean you could see the shame on some of
these cops faces down over there
we're not here to discuss whether or not
you're not here to discuss whether or
not the unconscious you're just here to
do your job right
[Music]
now
and you're going to enforce that
regardless right yeah
so you're part of the problem man I want
you to know that you're part of the
problem you're part of the problem
you're part of the problem
you're part of the problem everybody in
here every one of you man what's going
on in this country right now the reason
that we're in the situation we're in as
the United States of America you're part
of the problem sir
so you can't complain about what the
president is doing you can't complain
about the state that the country is in
right now you can't you can't complain
about how screwed up it is you're part
of the problem sir you're just doing
your job
so many people were just doing their job
for Hitler back in Germany
you as well sir that goes that goes for
you as well that goes for you as well
that goes for all of you
that goes for all of you man there's no
excuse there's zero excuse
just doing my job
that's not an excuse anymore man it's
not an excuse and you know what you know
why these cops don't care because they
know literally nothing will happen they
or I should say they think and um maybe
the simple the simple reality is just
say
first of all I want to be careful here I
want to make sure I stress this point
the Covington cans a video comes out
they accuse the kids of wrongdoing we
don't know for sure so we have the
general story here this has been an
ongoing thing and the general idea they
shut this guy down over refusing to
abide by the unconstitutional mandates
now the cops years later when the
mandates aren't in place anymore are
coming after him and causing damage to
his life
I want to make sure we're careful
because I'll say this make sure you look
into this don't be a knee-jerk
reactionary like the left was the
Covenant kids but assuming all the
reporting we have is true then you
should simply say to these officers uh
you're not welcome in my place of
business I don't want you coming around
my family I don't want you in my church
you are evil people it's the banality of
evil but uh uh Chef gruel I mean you
defied or I should say you spoke out
against so and what are your thoughts
seeing this story well I you know and I
think that's thank you for kind of
clarifying um because you're right you
don't know the back story here but just
looking at that video in and of itself I
can only imagine that it's nothing too
serious because number one if this guy
was doing anything that was criminal
he'd be arrested immediately if he was
doing something that was a violative of
ending Health standards he would be shut
down immediately gas would be cut from
his stores there would be messaging out
there so assuming that this is the
limitations on this you know two years
previous I mean that's just absurd and
the absurdity in general of a lot of
these mandates as I've talked about for
the past two years and have been
punished for doing so it people
understand it now right so you kind of
have this reverse process where now the
government which is typically behind the
times they are so far behind the times
that you have all people of both parties
looking at the absurdity of what went
down during covet in many cases not all
cases that making the case that this
just shouldn't be happening is a much
easier case to make but yet it's still
happening I cannot I mean two years
later that is absolutely nuts and you
had mentioned about 10 minutes ago you
said you know it was coveted and now
it's the next thing I don't think it's
the next thing I think we're in act
number 417 on covet and I think the
drama or the tragedy is going to
continue forward and they're going to
keep writing sequels to it with covid
being kind of the the main hero here
well they're going to try to milk this
cow as much as they can uh but we have
to understand with this particular case
looking into it there was a long series
of court cases okay and there was a
ruling that came down which now allowed
the government to come in and seize
their records and to seize their liquor
license so this is what happened here
and we have to understand the lunacy
that people had to go through within the
last few years how absolutely insane how
absolutely evil it was in California
there was businesses that that were
padlocked there was restaurants that
were shut down there was there was
businesses that had electricity cut by
the city because they dared to defy
their arbitrary lockdown orders
meanwhile Walmart was allowed to be open
Costco was allowed to be open all these
big box stores with connections to
politicians they were able to to run
their businesses police officers came on
Grandma's door knocked it down because
she dared to keep her business open even
when she had an online business the
stories that happened here in the United
States should terrify people because it
highlights the story of or of order
followers doing what they're told
committing human rights violations
against people of this country real
quick sorry just uh uh Matt Strickland I
see an individual became a member of the
channel right now and it looks it may be
the Matt Strickland who's in this story
so uh Matt if you are listening I just
followed you on Twitter shoot me a DM if
you want to say anything right now about
the subject matter and we'd love to meet
up maybe this weekend talk about what's
going on but you were saying nice I love
that um and that's that's the beauty of
communication right there if that's the
case I was going to say that you know
some of these some of these stories
truly underscore the indifference that
government has for people you say human
the human rights issues I mean so if you
look in California they shut down
outdoor dining in the December of 2020
okay 75 degrees and sunny in Southern
California they shut door shut down
outdoor dining and then this was
concurrent with the state of California
saying oh and by the way you can't get
any unemployment funds until January
February because we've misappropriated
80 billion dollars in unemployment funds
so you shut down outdoor dining this is
the truth of what happened all these
people got fired like 80 of the
restaurant industry and SoCal got fired
oh and by the way it's going into the
holidays and Christmas and you have no
money because the unemployment funds
aren't available you had people just
left on the streets which is why we
started the fun to raise money we're
driving around the Night Before
Christmas handing out 500 checks and
giving people their rent money because
we had the raise the funds as
individuals because the government
wasn't going to do anything to help
these people meanwhile what happened
what was the result of these policies
the rich became richer than they ever
have before it was the it was a policy
that committed the largest transfer of
wealth from some of the poorest some of
the most people some of the few people
left in the middle class to the richest
billionaires that of course were able to
keep their online businesses open they
were able to do things that violated
health and cold protocols but but that
didn't matter it was essentially a
deliberate action I believe a lot of
this was actually done on purpose to
shut people down to to make sure that
they will won't have any wealth with
their families yeah it seems like it's
like trying to trying to get back at
someone you don't like because they made
you angry but the reality in reality uh
law enforcement is there's an ethical
quality to it like if jaywalking is
illegal fine if you're out in the middle
of the street because there's a little
baby laying there and you get you're
jaywalking to get that baby off the road
you're not going to get arrested you may
have jaywalked they're not going to find
you for that one because you did the
right thing in violation of the law
sometimes people see the forest through
the trees and just because there's a
top-down Creed doesn't mean that you
have to fall in line
uh sort of go after people that stayed
open during what they want to call a
pandemic in a time that how many people
like how much death did keeping that
restaurant create open create let's find
that out because if so if they're if
they if they murdered people with Keith
staying open put them in prison but if
they didn't what the hell is going on
Sweden has uh uh there's a there's a
tweet I put out a while ago someone
posted the data Sweden's all-cause
mortality or whatever it's called is
like lower than most of Europe and they
had no lockdowns or they had very very
limited restrictions so we're looking at
this data you can make an argument for
Sweden's weather they're they're further
north smaller population maybe more
spread out but on the surface you look
at the data and we don't see any strong
I mean look at Florida yeah I mean
Florida didn't lock down
well Donald Trump was telling Sweden to
lock down was saying Sweden's was going
to have a mashed casualty event this was
the the president of the United States
saying this and he was absolutely wrong
on on a lot of these things as his
administration started the two weeks to
slow the spread nonsense which which
again was absolutely ridiculous as the
government their only plan was to give
you a two thousand dollar check which
they couldn't even give you out in the
correct way they couldn't even get that
right uh but but what did that what did
that do that that only indebted this
country that only made people more
reliant on government and it gave them
not even a Band-Aid it gave him it was
like someone was on fire and the
government spat on you that's that's
exactly what I could kind of quantify to
the government giving you a two thousand
dollar check and some of the people were
really happy they were like yeah this is
it wasn't that money is going to have to
be accounted for paid for in some kind
of way what we saw with these lockdowns
what with these restrictions was
essentially the elites playing with
everyone saying let's see how far we
could push the this let's see how we
could how much we could torture them
let's see how much we could get away
with when it comes to stealing
everything from them including their own
businesses and seeing that was was cruel
and it was evil I want you guys to
remember
when they published videos of a
restaurant and I think it was Leesburg
going outside and grabbing cicadas Off
the Wall bringing them inside cooking
them and serving them to people this was
very illegal it was a food truck no no
it was a brick and mortar place and then
they got told they got shut down like
you can't sell these cicada tacos
anymore because you can't just take bugs
off the street and then cook them and
feed them to people that's what they had
people doing remember all of these news
stories eat the bugs eat the bugs yeah
that was actually celebrated as being
very uh avant-garde did you did you cook
any bugs no we don't well first of all I
think that the idea of cooking cicadas
is disgusting
chef and they're they're also a
derivative of shrimp so if you have a
shellfish allergy and you're out there
cooking cicadas to try and be cute
you're gonna die if you eat a cicada
Taco number one number two we don't know
where these cicadas have been and if you
look at their life cycle actually
they're full of toxins but that's okay
go ahead and eat the cicadas oh let me
just say also this this clear statement
shutting down outdoor dining in Southern
California killed people yes because
when and because of the fact that people
weren't going out and sitting in an
outdoor area to go out to eat with their
friends and family everybody needs to go
out they need that social time what they
did was they had private House parties
in small enclosed areas instead elderly
people Etc and they got covered and they
died eating outside in 75 degree weather
we knew scientifically because we all
saw the headlines that the protests
Outdoors were totally safe right
remember that totally safe but we shut
down outdoor dining people died as a
result of that I do not understand the
outdoor dining shutdown well why why did
they do it they said that well the
answer was they said that the image that
it gives to people out celebrating and
dining Outdoors is that it's okay to be
outside during covet so you see how this
is all about the image the picture the
symbolism and I will give credit to the
Orange County uh sheriff's department
and all the police force in Orange
County we did remain open outdoors and
we did we continued to serve outside we
got a ton of support our sales were
tripled and the the police force said
you're good to go we're not going to
enforce any of these rules so there are
local jurisdictions where there are
there are officers there standing up and
saying look we're not going to stand
behind these absurd regulations or
mandates
um and uh you know those are the places
you got to seek out and celebrate it was
arbitrary it was it was made up real
quick Matt just hit me up and he said
that he guarantees one thousand percent
the only reason they came after him was
because he did not follow the coveted
mandates and you know he he'd like to
come join us and talk about it more
that'd be fantastic and uh thanks for
hitting me up brother uh I I'm sick of
seeing this stuff I'm sick of seeing all
these stories where you know we want to
come out and be like the defund the
police like well not Luke anyway but the
defund the police stuff goes too far
there there's a role for police the
average person who's not an anarchist or
or hardcore libertarian probably likes
the police but we cannot tolerate the
worst accesses of it now I know Luke's
solution is typically like no it's all
bad the police are ineffective they have
no incentive to actually provide you a
service they have no incentive at all
and and majority of crimes go unsolved
just especially when it comes to to to
to rape so especially when it comes to
homicides especially when it comes to
very serious situations a lot of the
times you're left on your own so why not
just officially be on your own and be
prepared to defend yourself the
incentive really for a police officer is
to protect its Community his or her
community because if your neighbors are
getting so is this what these guys are
doing
um
do you feel protected when when you're
pulled over by a police officer on a
motorcycle that's writing you a ticket
for not wearing a seat belt
do you feel protected if I don't have a
seatbelt if I'm speeding and I get
pulled over I thank the cop because I'm
I'm endangering the community it looks
right sorry no dude I mean see they're
on the motorcycle
thank you officer I was like oh come on
I pointed I was like come on and he went
get like like I'm gonna throw you in
jail if you do not it's not for your
safety it's it's for them to generate
Revenue people speeding are just out
there to kill I don't think people
should well hold on hold on someone's
speeding like I don't know 20 15 20
miles over I understand but Luke's got a
good point let's break that down like
you can't you have to wear a seat belt
in your car but the cop on a motorcycle
is literally just sitting on this thing
going 60 miles an hour you know what I
mean it is silly it's not for your
safety well I think it is they pull you
over they'll be like yo put your
seatbelt on because if someone hits you
you're gonna get killed they don't want
to clean up a bloody blood but there's
better ways of incentivizing those kind
of policies like he's on a motorcycle
right yes he has to weave through
traffic no but like he has to speed up
go faster than you are on a motorcycle
and and you know it's to get through
cars but isn't it like one in like 20 20
to 25 of people will suffer some kind of
accident on a motorcycle oh dude my Dad
ran himself over with a motorcycle one
time is he like he just flipped over the
front and then it went over him people
should be allowed to motorcycle I I got
a motorcycle they're great fun but there
is something that's inherently silly
about a motorcycle cop giving a ticket
for not wearing a seat belt like you are
safer without the seat belt in the car
then they are just on the motorcycle
following all the regulations yeah and
this is what a lot of the lockdowns were
all about it's all about protecting it
wasn't about protecting anyone it was
literally Dr fauci and other health
officials who weren't healthy a lot of
them were obese a lot of them were
disgusting a lot of them were just
absolutely unhealthy beasts sitting
there eating their donuts telling you
hey you know we'll give you free donuts
if you if you do this but you gotta also
jump through our Hoops that we're going
to literally make up the the documents
came out from the fauci emails and a lot
of these rules they're like hey where
did you think of these these six feet
where did you think of these Plexiglas
where's the science and logic behind it
and they were like oh there's none
there's is absolutely none of that it's
me just making things up as I go along
and the latest scientific data is
highlighting how a lot of these
protocols a lot of these things actually
made the situation that much worse and
more people got sick as a result of it
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time